تضاؤلوا مخزونات روسيا العسكريه بسبب
تدمير او فقدان الياتها في ساحه المعركه
الاوكرانيه اوجد الحاجه للارتجال فلوسيا
وروسيا التي تمتلك ثاني اكبر جيش في
العالم تتجه نحو طرق بدائيه لتهجين
الاسلحه وتعويض النقص وفق تقرير للذيل صور
نشرتها الصحيفه البريطانيه تظهر اقدام
موسكو على لحم او تركيب الابراج البحريه
القديمه على سطح عربات مدرعه اقدم لصنع
الدبابات بدائيه البرج البحري مشاهدينا
مضاد لطائرات عيار 25 ملي مترا تم تركيبه
على مركبه قتاليه وهي تو ام 3 برمائيه اي
ام تي ال بي من الحقبه السوفييتيه هذه
المركبات الهجينه ذات تصميم الهندسيه
السيء وفق وصف بعض الخبراء العسكريين
لديها هدفين اولهما محاوله اسقاط سيارات
الاوكرانيه اما ثاني هما فارسال هذه
المدرعات الى جزء اكثر هدوءا من خط
المواجهه حتى تتمكن طبعا القوات الروسيه
من نقل تكنولوجيا افضل الى المعارك
الرئيسيه هنا مسؤول عسكري بريطاني سابق
اكد ان مركبات مماثله شوهدت فقط
في سوريا وحذر من ان قيام جيش بضخامه
الجيش الروسي بجمع معدات مثل الجماعات
الارهابيه يؤكد هنا مجددا خطوره الوضع
الروسي في اوكرانيا علما بان احاطه
استخباراتي بريطانيه اشارت الى اخراج
روسيا 800 دبابه عمرها يزيد عن 60 عاما من
مخازنها كما رجحت استبدال دبابات الحرس
الاول والتي يفترض انها قوه الدبابات
الاولى في روسيا بدبابات
مضيفه ان القياده العسكريه ترسل مقاتلين
مسلحين بمعاون ومجارف فقط لج بهات القتال
[موسيقى]